[Music]
one of the biggest-selling girl groups
of all time TLC today the band made big
news they postponed the European leg of
their world tour because Tionne t-boz
Watkins is dealing with health issues
here's the thing it's nothing new for
the singer we talked about her everyday
struggles to stay alive and how they led
to one of their biggest hits ever tell
me the story behind unpretty writing on
print oh wow I'm pretty I watch a Ricki
Lake and these men were downing women
calling them fat and all this stuff and
I said you know what society has a way
of making us feel like we're not good
enough to fit in some write a poem
called unpretty
[Music]
so there came to song number one t-boz
is booty and TLC delivery after hit but
behind the scenes the singer struggles
with the debilitating effects of
sickle-cell disease the doctors told you
you shouldn't be here right now you
should have died a long time ago that
you wouldn't make it to the age of
thirty correct and I would never have
kids and I'd be disabled my whole life
even at the height of her fame she
struggled with pain it's a daily process
for me geez a lot of times like let's
say for the pay-per-view HBO special we
did I was rolled out of the hospital in
a wheelchair to the stage and right back
to the hospital after the show I was on
so much medication they had security
around the stage to make sure I didn't
fall off in her new book a sick life she
describes how she went on to defy the
odds in 2000 t-boz gave birth to her
daughter chase afterwards she fell into
a coma for three days I just remember
waking up and my mom telling the nurse
to lay the baby on my heart and I
remember her whispering Tionne you have
someone to live for and that is what
pushed me through that coma that was
followed up by another health crisis in
2006 a brain tumor how hard was it to
work your way back Oh three and a half
years the physical therapy I couldn't
close my eyes I couldn't inform words I
lost my speech my sight my hearing and
they took my balance completely from the
right side what is it about you you keep
just pushing through I kids to live for
I have a fight in me that I want to live
like so you can either what was me and
dwell on it and feel bad for you sober
you get up and fight so I'm gonna fight
I bow down to this woman and all the
things that she survived in her life a
sick life is out right now at your
neighborhood book store go check it out
[Music]
you